attention 1 j'entends rien 2
3 alors ça c'est joli un showine des
plus grandes universités américaines à
la faculté de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
samedi 12 mars quelques 1800 étudiants
ayant validé leur master l'année
dernière ont participé à cette première
cérémonie des remises de diplôme chapeau
to et écharpe été de mise on sait que on
va la mettre une fois après on on va la
garder en tant que en tant que souvenir
mais bon c'est ENF ça fait quelque chose
de de particulier j'ai trouvé très
intéressant le fait que cette année on a
une remise de diplôme assez officielle
c'est qu chose qui est important parce
que ça permet d'acacter le fait qu'on
soit diplômé et c'est une reconnaissance
de la part de T de des professeurs et
puis dire voilà nous aussi nous sommes
diplômés enseignants élus responsable de
formation famille près de 3000 personnes
étaient réunies pour assister à cet
événement il y a une certaine portée
symbolique il quitte un peu le le monde
du coconing de l'université le monde de
l'enfance pour passer dans le monde de
des adultes responsables l'enjeu est
avant tout de montrer la qualité des
formations et de la recherche de l'vsq
je pense c'est important de pouvoir à
l'occasion des 25 ans de l'université
rassembler dans un lieu un peu magique
donc l'ensemble de l'université C aussi
important par rapport à l'ancrage
d'université dansuniversité Paris sa-clé
montrer peti démonstration de force et
de qualité 20000 étudiants sont inscrits
dans les de formations de l'université
les 80 Masters de l'UVSQ font partie
pour la grande majorité de de formation
de l'Université Paris SACL dont elle est
membre fondateur magnifique